in 1956 a documentary by Jacques
Cousteau won both the Pongo and an Oscar
award this film was called namond do
silence or the silent world and the
premise of the title was that the
underwater world was a quiet world we
now know 60 years later that the
underwater world is anything but silent
although the sounds are inaudible above
water depending upon where you are and
the time of year the underwater
soundscape can be as noisy as any jungle
or rainforest invertebrates like
snapping shrimp fish and marine mammals
all use sound they use sound to study
their habitats to keep in communication
with each other to navigate to detect
predators and prey and they also use
sound by listening to know something
about their environment take for an
example the Arctic it's considered a
vast inhospitable place sometimes
described as a desert because it is so
cold and so remote and ice-covered for
much of the year and despite this there
is no place on earth that I would rather
be than the Arctic
especially as days lengthen and spring
comes and to me the Arctic really
embodies this disconnect between what we
see on the surface and what's going on
underwater you can look out across the
ice all white and blue and cold and see
nothing but if you could hear underwater
the sound you would hear would it first
a maze and then delight you and while
your eyes are seeing nothing for
kilometres but ice your ears are telling
you that out there are bowhead and
beluga whales
walrus and bearded seals the ice to make
sounds it screeches and cracks and pops
and groans as it collides and rubs when
temperature or currents or winds change
and under a hundred percent sea ice in
the dead of winter
bowhead whales are singing and you would
never expect that because we humans we
tend to be very visual animals for most
of us but not all our sense of sight is
how we navigate our world for marine
mammals that live underwater where
chemical cues and light transmit poorly
sound is the sense by which they see and
sound transmits very well underwater
much better than it does in air and so
signals can be heard over great
distances and in the Arctic this is
especially important because not only do
Arctic marine mammals have to hear each
other but they also have to listen for
cues in the environment that might
indicate heavy ice ahead or open water
remember although they spend most of
their lives underwater they are mammals
and so they have to surface to breathe
so they might listen for thin ice or no
ice or listen for echoes off nearby ice
Arctic marine mammals live in a rich and
varied underwater soundscape in the
spring it can be a cacophony of sound
[Music]
[Applause]
but when the ice is frozen solid and
there's no big temperature shifts or
current changes the underwater Arctic
has some of the lowest ambient noise
levels of the world's oceans but this is
changing this is primarily due to a
decrease in seasonal sea ice which is a
direct result of human greenhouse gas
emissions we are in effect with climate
change conducting a completely
uncontrolled experiment with our planet
over the past 30 years areas of the
Arctic have seen decreases in seasonal
sea ice from anywhere from six weeks to
four months and this decrease in sea ice
is sometimes referred to as an increase
in the open water season that is the
time of year when the Arctic is
navigable to vessels and not only is the
extent of ice changing but the age and
the width of ice is - now you may well
have heard that a decrease in seasonal
sea ice is causing loss of habitat for
animals that rely on sea ice such as ice
fields or walrus or polar bears
decreasing sea ice is also causing
increased erosion along coastal villages
and changing prey availability for
marine birds and mammals climate change
and decreases in sea ice are also
altering the underwater soundscape of
the Arctic now what do I mean by
soundscape those of us who eavesdrop on
the oceans for a living
use instruments called hydrophones which
are underwater microphones and we record
ambient noise the noise all around us
and the soundscape describes the
different contributors to this noise
field and what we are hearing on our
hydrophones are the very real sounds of
climate change
and we are hearing these changes from
three fronts from the air from the water
and from land first air wind on water
creates waves these waves make bubbles
the bubbles break and when they do they
make noise and this noise is like a hiss
or a static in the background now in the
Arctic when it's ice-covered
most of the noise from wind doesn't make
it into the water column because the ice
acts as a buffer between the atmosphere
and the water and this is one of the
reasons that the Arctic can have very
low ambient noise levels but with
decreases in seasonal sea ice not only
is the Arctic now open to this wave
noise but the number of storms and the
intensity of storms in the Arctic has
been increasing all of this is raising
noise levels in a previously quiet ocean
second water with less seasonal sea ice
subarctic species are moving north and
taking advantage of the new habitat that
is created by more open water now arctic
whales like this bow head they have no
dorsal fin because they have evolved to
live and swim in ice-covered waters and
having something sticking off of your
back is not very conducive to migrating
through ice and may in fact be excluding
animals from the ice but now everywhere
we've listened we're hearing the sounds
of sin whales and humpback whales and
killer whales further and further north
and later and later in the season we are
hearing in essence an invasion of the
Arctic by subarctic species and we don't
know what this means
will there be competition for food
between Arctic and subarctic animals
might be subarctic species introduce
diseases or parasites into the Arctic
and what are the new sounds that they
are producing doing to the soundscape
underwater and
bird land and buy land I mean people
more open water means increased human
use of the Arctic just this past summer
a massive cruise ship made its way
through the Northwest Passage the ones
mythical route between Europe in the
Pacific decreases in sea ice have
allowed humans to occupy the Arctic more
often it is allowed increases in oil and
gas exploration and extraction the
potential for commercial shipping as
well as increased tourism and we now
know that shift noise increases levels
of stress hormones and whales and can
disrupt feeding behavior airguns
which produce loud low-frequency rooms
every 10 to 20 seconds change the
swimming and vocal behavior of whales
and all of these sound sources are
decreasing the acoustic space over which
Arctic marine mammals can communicate
now Arctic marine mammals are used to
very high levels of noise at certain
times of the year but this is primarily
from other animals or from sea ice and
these are the sounds with which they've
evolved and these are sounds that are
vital to their very survival these new
sounds are loud and they're alien and
they might impact the environment in
ways that we think we understand but
also in ways that we don't remember
sound is the most important sense for
these animals and not only is the
physical habitat of the Arctic changing
rapidly
but the acoustic habitat is - it's as if
we pluck these animals up from the quiet
countryside and drop them into a big
city in the middle of rush hour and they
can't escape it so what can we do now
we can't decrease wind speeds or keep
subarctic animals from migrating north
but we can work on local solutions to
reducing human caused underwater noise
one of these solutions is to slow down
ships that traverse the Arctic because a
slower ship is a quieter ship we can
restrict access in seasons and regions
that are important for mating or feeding
or migrating we can get smarter about
quieting ships and find better ways to
explore the ocean bottom and the good
news is there are people working on this
right now but ultimately we humans have
to do the hard work of reversing or at
the very least decelerating human caused
atmospheric changes so let's return to
this idea of a silent world underwater
it's entirely possible that many of the
whales swimming in the Arctic today
especially long-lived species like the
bowhead whale but the intimates say can
live to human lives it's possible that
these whales were alive in 1956 when
Jacques Cousteau made his film and in
retrospect considering all the noise we
are creating in the oceans today perhaps
it really was the silent world thank you
[Applause]